[MUSIC PLAYING]
Professor Terence
Tao is the equivalent
of a rock star in mathematics.
Regarded as the greatest
mathematician alive.
As long as I can
remember, I have always
loved numbers and
puzzles and patterns.
Sometimes, because of
the way it's taught,
innate mathematical ability
doesn't feel connected
to the way we learn math.
But I think we all have an
innate ability for mathematics.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Knowing how to
think mathematically
can be a tool that you
can use to solve problems
in a systematic way.
I like to think that this
class is for anyone, really.
In fact, maybe this class
is even more suitable
for people who have not had
formal mathematical training.
I'm not going to
give you homework.
The way I approached
problems in mathematics
was to try to turn
it into a game.
A large part of
this class will be
about talking about
problem solving.
We abstract them.
We break them up into pieces.
We make analogies.
We try to find connections
with other problems.
The first player who can collect
three numbers that add up to 15
wins the game.
Playing this game
is quite challenging
if you don't know the trick.
You can transform this to
a much more familiar game,
tic-tac-toe.
People often anthropomorphize
mathematical objects.
They call this guy the enemy.
This guy's your friend.
Some people call them slightly
more obscene names, okay, but--
[LAUGHS]
In this class, you'll appreciate
a little bit more what
mathematics is, how
we solve problems,
and how some of these
strategies can be of use to you
in your daily life.
The ideal problem
to work on is one
which is just barely
outside of your reach.
It's not so much whether
you succeed or fail
at the question.
But it's whether you can
learn something from it.
My name is Terence Tao,
and this is MasterClass.
[MUSIC PLAYING]